he has reason to celebrate only days
before Roger stone was to begin a 40
month prison sentence his friend Donald
Trump came to his aid numerous occasions
that he thought there was a good chance
I could be exonerated I agree with that
but this is a this is a [ __ ] off
horrific nightmare when you realize that
this is this investigation never had any
legitimate or lawful beginning it was a
witch hunt
in February stone had been sentenced for
lying to Congress witness tampering and
obstructing the house investigation into
whether the Trump campaign colluded with
Russia to win the 2016 election in an
official statement that was published on
Friday the Trump administration called
stone a victim of the Russia hoax that
the left and his allies in the media
perpetrated four years in an attempt to
undermine the Trump presidency
although US President Donald Trump has
repeatedly stepped in to protect his
associates this Marxist highest profile
intervention in a criminal case House
Intelligence Committee Chair Adam Schiff
tweeted with Trump they are now two
systems of justice in America one for
Trump's criminal friends and one for
everyone else and Trump's rival in the
upcoming presidential election Joe Biden
wrote that Donald Trump has surrounded
himself with people who flout our laws
we shouldn't be surprised that he thinks
he's above the law
even if critics might be shocked at
Trump's use of his unlimited pardoning
power his strongest supporters are
unlikely to be deterred by it for his
longtime political confident Roger stone
the president's willingness to help out
his friends has helped pave the road to
freedom for more I'm joined by GW
reporter Aaron hilf s'en why is Donald
Trump doing this well today's actions
shouldn't come as any surprise anyone
has really been following the stone case
I mean stone was of course convicted of
obstruction of justice witness tampering
in line to Congress in connection
investigation and that looked into
possible connections between the
election campaign of Donald Trump and
the Russian government now that is of
course something that Trump has long
maintained was an illegitimate
investigation you know he do phrased it
as a partisan witch hunt in a hoax which
is part of the reason he said that stone
should never have actually faced trial
in the United States
now that is of course something that a
jury of Roger stones peers disagreed
with which is why he was sentenced to
just over three years in prison what's
interesting about today's actions from
Donald Trump is actually that he didn't
show choose to pardon on stone instead
he commuted his sentence which means in
the eyes of the criminal justice system
from America Roger stone was still a
convicted criminal but by commuting his
sentence Trump has managed to keep his
promise and is keeping him out of jail
what reaction have we had from Democrats
today well if you ask most the Democrats
the United States today is not a good
day for the American justice system now
they have long accused both the Justice
Department under Trump and Trump himself
of having a heavy-handed approach and
actually getting involved in a bevy of
different criminal cases in order to
keep his associates and aides and allies
out of prison they've also accused him
of using the the power of pardon to make
sure that political allies remain out of
prison and don't actually see a day of
jail time in a bunch of different cases
it's part of the reason that Adam Schiff
one prominent Democrat actually said
that a today Trump has again made it
clear that there are two systems of
justice in America one for Donald
Trump's criminal friends and one for
everyone else so again we're seeing the
sharp political divide coming out in the
United States once again how will this
have an effect on the Trump campaign for
re-election to be absolutely honest you
know Donald Trump is facing a large
uphill fight to stay in the White House
he's really down in the polls but I
don't see this really hurting him among
independents or Democrats because I mean
let's face it if they're not going to
vote for Donald Trump in the fall it's
for a bevy of different reasons it's not
because he's keeping Roger stone out of
prison when it comes to his base I
actually see this plane quite well
because many people actually voted for
Donald Trump because
they were expecting a more forceful
approach to politics and you know he's
been facing month after month of bad
news in recent memories so I you know I
see this actually plain to him as his
base where this allows him to set the
agenda again and kind of say you know
I'm returning to the old form of back
you know as he was in 2017 and 2018 so I
don't see him he'd see this hurting him
in the long term
Thank You IRA Nelson ddw reports thank
you